Alright folks, welcome back.
This is our review and final discussion in the free 2022 ITT Mentorship for YouTube.
So this is June 23rd, 2022 and we're looking at the e-mini SMP September contract for 2022
and this is an hourly chart. So I'm cutting right to the chase here and this morning on Twitter
I was looking at, well I was expecting actually a little bit more volatility around the Fed chair
Powell speaking at 10 o'clock in the morning and we didn't get a whole lot of excitement but we
did get to see ICT's expectation fall short. So that's one of the benefits of seeing it live with
me. An expectation, an analysis, a call, a viewpoint, a perspective, opinion, not coming to pass.
Okay and time of day, how I used it and how you should use it going forward and also how it kept
me from looking at an incorrect setup that would otherwise maybe a catalyst for you having had a
incorrect setup this morning and I'll talk about that in a moment but for now this is the framework
for today. We had sell-side liquidity here, the market dropped down, took that sell-side out, rallied
up, buy-side here. I was looking for 3805 level today and this is the reason why and I was looking
at it early on in the morning. I wanted to see it run up here and hit that. If it was gonna hit
it I would have been watching for a potential short deform but it didn't do it. So that was
my expectation based on this high back here. We already took sell-side so I was looking for
a little bit deeper run into this high here when we just went just above that short-term high there
and gave up the ghost and went lower and I had a trade that got stopped up plus two points and I'll
talk about that when we get into the lower time time frame. Alright so here is the 15 minute
time frame and usually I have the charts blank and I'll ask you to take a look at it. I don't
want to do that tonight because I want to get to the teachings at the end to kind of like bring
this entire mentorship to a close. The teachings itself will end for this model in this lesson.
So technically there's 41 videos that make up this mentorship so if you take away the introductory
video it's basically what 40 even so that's not bad. Hopefully you found it insightful and helpful
but looking at this morning we had the 10 o'clock pow event here and the market started to run up
and we took out the buy-side here but again I was aiming for this. This is what I wanted to see. I
want to see it run up here and actually took a long in here. I was wanting to see it run up into
that level and I was going to do a reversal and it didn't obviously give it to me. So notice the
time of day here. This is New York index a.m. session operating hours or kilton if you want
to call it that and it's 830 in the morning till 11. Now I can take trades after 11 o'clock but I
want to kind of like stick to the rules and present you opportunities to see where following
the rules you're gonna miss certain opportunities it's okay it's fine you're gonna get it wrong
sometimes you watch me get something wrong today there was no skin off my back nothing you know
bad happened is I didn't get what I was looking for and because it was late in the day as we'll
look at the lower time frame in a moment but it ran above the short-term buy-side liquidity here
I wanted it to run up to here but it broke down and I was telling myself and also even use public
on Twitter that I wasn't interested and I wasn't quite sure what it wanted to do because it was
approaching that noon hour and I took a trade and out plus two so in other words I was just
covering expenses basically and I was wrong on the initial run so when I have that scenario and
it's off of a Fed chair or a high-impact news event and it didn't pan out like I was expecting
it to in my experience it's been better for me to just move away and say okay I'm gonna close
the computer and I'll come back later on and see what's going on and I didn't want to trade any
more of the morning session leading into noon so I had waited and I was gonna take a look at what
it did in lunch hour and post lunch hour around 1 30 and see what there was opportunity to do
anything then but we have a fair value gap on the 15th time frame here see that so the market
eventually after running the buy-side here drew all the way down took out sell side here overrun
this fair bag gap here why did it do that because this is a larger one so if it's gonna go over top
of this one and trade to the top of this candle which is the low end of that fair bag gap that's
here that's not noted on showing your by the respective candles it's gonna go here that's
also the high end of the fair bag gap here so it's likely to go over top of this one and run into
this one okay it does that as we're going into the noon lunch hour in New York until
one o'clock where it makes the low of the session after closing in the fair value gap and then the
130 to 4 New York local time that's the p.m. session New York index p.m. session or afternoon
session for index trading and the market started to create a willingness to want to go higher
we'll look at a short term shift in market structure when we get in the lower time frame
but it draws all the way back up to the target I was looking for in the morning so the expectation
of going to that specific level let me explain to you what I was looking for I wanted to go above
hit that and then sell off and go down to this area here for a discount and then create the run
and then go beyond 3805 that's what I was really looking for today that's what I wanted to do but
it failed to get to 3805 it fell down into this area here and I knew once it broke here I don't
want to go short because I'm going into lunch hour and I was concerned it was going to consolidate
a lot and then take forever to get down into and I don't want to hold anything new into lunch so
I prefer to see some kind of a stop run in the lunch hour which is what we're seeing here it runs
down below that and into a fair value gap deep discount between low high trades down into it and
then rallies up this session here we'll look at it on the five-minute chart so we can see obviously
the initial poke above here inside this area I was looking at a two-minute fair value gap I
mentioned that on Twitter as it was forming and it rallied up and then once it took the short-term
high out when this was a bold-faced bullish candle I was thinking to myself okay it could
expand up in here and I'm watching that and I had a tweet ready to go I'm gonna sell short here and
look for a rundown into this level here never got okay and there's some of you probably gonna
hear this and say oh yeah sure you sure you did I mean it is what it is folks I mean I was out
there without a safety net and I told everyone what I was expecting what I was looking for it
simply didn't pan out and that's okay but the market eventually breaks lower then after we get
into the lunch hour closing at one o'clock and then I personally like to wait till 130 because
it's a little bit more cleaner price action the market starts to rally away drops back down into
an order block a fair value gap on a five-minute chart then we have a shift in market structure
here on the five-minute chart creates a small little return to a fair value gap there rallies
another fair value gap it runs into it here rallies and eventually takes up the short-term
high of the day and then runs through the levels drawing your attention to on Twitter
all right so here's the five-minute chart zoomed in with the morning session you see the run here
on the buy side one more here and eventually breaking down displacement small little fair value
gap here rolls down into the fair value gap here and then once again returning back up into an
imbalance then runs down to the low end of the fair value gap turning basically at the low of
the session at the low end of the fair value gap at one o'clock so closure of lunch time hour it
creates that low this right here is the two-minute chart and this is the fair value gap I drew your
attention to live and it came down into it here and inside this fair value gap is basically
drawing your attention to that as a potential long I did and I was looking for a run into 3805
and it started the run took out the buy side here I mentioned the buy side would likely be a draw
on liquidity it was but I wanted to see a draw up to here that's the specific level I was looking
for and it the market comes back down into the fair value gap again once more and then rallies
above the short-term high here this right here would have been a nice opportunity for me to
basically say pay the trader and me take something after I tweeted that off but I didn't because I
wanted this level here okay now one could argue and say oh you're being greedy or you didn't follow
rules or you didn't do this and you didn't do that it's easy to armchair quarterback someone
and it's okay if you want to do that in the comment section that's fine but just know that
I'm doing this real time and I'm okay with being wrong wrong isn't gonna ruin me I'm not a hundred
percent but I'm generally on par better than the average bear okay we'll just say it that way
without sounding like I'm bragging but once it came back down in it stopped me out because I
rolled my stop up to a level that I wasn't willing to weather a deeper retracement because this is
the takeaway fair value gap we trade down into it we get movement that's good comes back down
and again complete closure of the fair value gap okay that's acceptable does it start to rallyway
yes that's why I felt confident that it was going to go up to here because if it's going to go above
here then it should just spread its wings and run that 38.05 level with no problem it wasn't
having it the market dropped back down and didn't quite take out this short-term low with any
displacement so while this fair value gap exists it's not one that I would have taken because we
didn't see a displacement with meaningful movement below that low so this is not a fair value gap
that I would have been a participant in so looking at that I'm thinking I'm not interested I'm gonna
close up shop and there it is because I didn't get this run below here now had I seen that I may
have I'm not gonna go out and on a limb and say absolutely but I may have if it would have shown
like this type of movement on this candle below that low and then we move back up in this right
here then I probably would have said well I'm gonna go short and aim for this low here and then
at noon if I didn't get here I would just close it off and then ride out the lunch hour so that
was kind of like what was going on in my head because it was an event around pal I didn't want
to give you guys a lot of things that be concerned about or get lost in the commentary and plus I
didn't want to be worrying about someone doing something hurting themselves I knew invariably
some of you are waiting there with a live account ready to click a button because I've said something
okay so that weighs heavily on me when I comment on Twitter so I just want you to be careful okay
do it in a demo don't do it a live account but we had another fair value gap in here trades up
into that nice closure perfectly and runs down to the top of the fair value gap on that 15-minute
time frame one more little bounce in and rolls over and goes deeper into the fair value cap
all right here is the afternoon session and this is where we're gonna be doing the bulk of the
discussion on the reading portion of this video and I'll frame the logic around risk management
and stop-loss management and that'll complete the model the rules I'm going to give you are
static they they're always the same so that way you know once you put a position on your demo
account where is your stop how much are you risking when do you move your stop okay and
this is the rule that I use and sometimes you've seen me show trades where I get in and I'm not
really trying to move my stop-loss I'm taking partials along the way but I'm not really trying
to rush my stop-loss up I'm gonna show you the rules I follow so that way it makes sense to you
and it'll help you also trust taking partials letting that become a better way of managing
its position in trade and not be fearful about being stopped out because the stop-loss is there
to do its job you pay it well to do that but if you're worrying about that stop-loss being tripped
versus following along in price action continuously measuring whether or not price is giving you what
you're expecting in terms of bullishness or bearishness is the institutional order flow still
bullish if you're long or is it still bearish when you're short those types of things are more
important than worrying about whether you're going to get stopped out or not that's not to
minimize obviously the the risk that's respected obviously you should be respecting the risk by
actually putting a hard stop in but if you don't put a hard stop in you're not really respecting
the risk what you're saying is is I'm risking this trade because I believe I'm right but if I'm wrong
I'll figure out where I'm wrong when it gets there you don't want to do that okay so anyway
we'll close that portion of the discussion at the end of the video but here it's a two minute chart
showing the afternoon or pm session for index futures and you see we traded down into
this is showing a weird time because it's two minutes but this is the one o'clock hour it hits
the low and then starts to rally up short term shift in market structure here key time of day
130 it trades back down into an order block last down close candle there is a fair value gap
right here I didn't note it because it's going to be too cluttered up and I'm going to be basically
doing a lot of discussion in this area and I don't want it to be over lapped with too many things to
be navigating so this is the 15 minute fair value gap and it's trading down to an order block after
a shift in market structure after trading down and closing in a 15 minute time frame
fair value gap and then it trades into an optimal trade entry which is the flagship pattern of this
youtube channel fair value gap with an order block and optimal trade entry is the gold standard
of the ict pattern that's taught on this youtube channel
this is where you can be long and expect price to reach for here and here
okay so we have objectives in here where we can look for this imbalance here
buy sell liquidity here buy sell liquidity here and we'll watch and see does it continuously march
higher so we have a run from here to the short term high then we have this fair value gap here
that runs here up into the 3005 level so this pm session I was long in and I'm not going to try
to build the case to outline everything because I want to give you what's salient to close this
mentorship and show you how to use stop placement risk management
and give you a working example and now some of you like to see
did I really take a trade yeah I was trading today so you can see here a live account
and one thousand nine hundred seventy five dollars okay back to the lesson and you'll see what it
means to go through the process of determining risk management and stop loss placement and when
you move your stop all right so we're zoomed in here and looking at the five minute chart
and again that's the fair value gap we're going to be using here to frame it so if you're looking
at the idea of you traded down into that fair value gap does it show a willingness to go higher
yes is there a short term shift in market structure yes is there a gap yes down close candle to the
left of it yes drops down in bullish order block optimal trade entry in other words that would be
a 62 to 7 improvement level less than equilibrium relative to the high and the low respectively
so we would be looking for a limit order to be at 37 54 75 we'll use that okay so one quarter
point less than this candle's low so that would be our hypothetical limit order to buy going long
and we're going to use the low here for our stop loss so 37 45.75
essentially nine points of risk okay so we'll come back that in a couple minutes but for now
what we'll be reaching for what will be the draw on liquidity from this high down to that low
we want to get to a premium level 50 percent's about right in here eyeballing it we don't need
to have a fiddle in that you should do it for yourself but then we have this imbalance here
so the first low hanging fruit objective will be this candle's high that's 37 80 and a quarter
so we're looking at about 25 and a half handles a potential points profit per contract so we're
risking nine points to make 25 and a half not bad it's better than two and a half are so you're
going to risk one dollar to make two dollars and 50 cents basically and that's on a run from here
to here we don't need to know if it's going to go up to here yet okay this right here is one trade
from here to here then it creates another opportunity in here where it can run from
here to here and we'll talk about that when it gets into the discussion on risk management trade
management all right so risk management anytime you're trying to consider what lot size or how
much you're supposed to be trading or whatever there are free tools if you google them okay it's
amazing how many folks ask me and other educators out there the most simplest questions that are
answered just by a google search okay i know it feels easier i think it's a matter of just
getting a personal response from the educator or whoever it is that you're asking and
it's not possible for me to go through every single person's question
and reply to them so hopefully you understand that there's just simply no way for me to do that
i don't have enough time in the day to do that nobody really does but simple things like
lot size calculators okay you can do a google search on that and there are some wonderful free
applications and tools that will make that known to you by you just plugging in how much money you
have in your account what risk percentage are you trying to use what size stop loss are you going to
use and it'll tell you how much leverage if you're trading forex or you know what your lot size should
lot size should be for futures now i understand that's probably not the response that you want
because you want to have an interactive experience with your educator or mentor but these are really
basic types of things that can be learned and understood and found the solution to by simply
doing a little bit of the legwork yourself with that said i'm going to give you one example here
and just kind of like walk it out for you assuming you had ten thousand dollars in
your trading index futures and you are using this trade idea that i'm outlining here
that i was monitoring in the afternoon session
ten thousand dollars is your equity you want to take one percent risk per trade so you're going
to take that ten thousand dollars times it by point zero one that's going to give you a figure
of one hundred that's one hundred dollars that's what one percent of ten thousand dollars is that
means that's the total amount of risk that you're willing to assume we determined from the hypothetical
entry of your demo account at thirty seven fifty four and three quarters and a stop at thirty seven
forty five and three quarters that's nine points or nine handles okay that's what that nine is
so we're taking the dollar amount which is the one percent of our equity
giving us one hundred dollars or one percent of ten thousand dollars
total movement that we're willing to absorb as a risk or a stop loss is nine points so we take
nine divide that into one hundred that gives us eleven okay eleven times we can get the figure
nine that eleven if we're going to trade a mini or e-mini futures contract on the s&p
the multiplier per contract is fifty bucks so divide fifty into eleven you can't so you right
away you know you can't trade a mini if you're going to be risking one percent so you have to
drop down into the micros so now we have eleven with the multiple of five so micro lot on e-mini
micro instead of fifty dollars per point it's five dollars per point so how many
five can you go into eleven with it two so you can do two micro lots now this might not be
for you because when i do risk management i don't really factor in commissions i'll just do the
math like this so you might look at that and say well what about commissions that might not allow
me to do one percent if you're going to be very hardline about the risk management and i get it
some of you should be like that in the beginning but as you get more experience you'll start
thinking oh you know the covered costs of commissions and such over time it's fine i'll
work that out but for risk management just for the entry to stop loss not factoring commission
costs and fees with your broker or spread okay all those ideas need to be considered
but we're going to assume that they're not going to be considered for this example
you have to figure that out on your own if that's how you're going to do your risk management but
for me i don't ever factor in the cost because costs are always going to be they're like taxes
you can't avoid them so just you eat it okay so you can do two micro lots at five dollars per
point making profit or taking and drawdown or loss per point fluctuation
so if we're buying at 3754 and three quarters and we're risking nine points
how much money is that 90 risk so we're under one percent so we're not even risking a full one
percent our target is 25 and a half points or 255 because two micro at five dollars at the
multiplier of each point two times five is ten so you're making ten dollars per point
because you're holding two micros so 25 and a half points here at ten dollars total multiplier
based on the two micro lots which would be basically two and a quarter percent return
so you're going to risk one percent to make two and a quarter percent on one intraday scalp
here and then you have another one here and if you were trying to do shorts over here you could
have done something equivalent to that as well so it's not hard to make one to three to five percent
in one day with intraday price swings the problem is you're going to get overexcited
and think that you can do every single fluctuation in price action and these types of movements
while they're exciting when you do the math on them and you see the potential a lot of times
people will say well one percent i can't make money with one percent man you can make a lot
of money with one percent okay if you can make one percent a day that's enormous because that
compounds over time and it's not a matter of saying well if i make one percent a day and i
do that monday through friday that means i made five percent at the end of the week or 20 percent
for the month correct that's what most of you are probably thinking right now when in fact you're
actually able to get 22 percent a month because of the effects of compounding you do one percent
per day trading monday through friday four weeks average per month one could make 22 percent a
month now 22 percent a month it's phenomenal like that's ridiculous rates of return professional
money managers and fund managers don't try to do that for a whole year some of them do anywhere
between 12 to 15 percent a year and they call that an stellar year and if they make 20 percent
or more you know that's a blockbuster year and they're parade around in front of their clients
they see that type of return and bolster their confidence to put more money in that's usually
when they'll say hey you want to allocate more money because they get paid to do that well one
percent is in my opinion obviously you know it's not going to be the case for a new student or a
new trader but in my opinion one percent every single day is unrealistic but for a seasoned
trader one percent average per day is really easy but you're going to have to get the experience to
do that and again that also equates to the average of one percent so in other words if i have one
trade a week and i make five percent that's equivalent to one percent a day
for the week i'm not going to sit in front of the charts to try to make one percent each day
it's not reasonable for me i have things i have to take care of have businesses around and family
that tend to and i can find setups that i can frame and make you know five percent on one setup
or first partial of a trade so it's a matter how you're going to form fit this for yourself
okay and obviously the best scenario would be if you're going to be eventually getting to a point
we can risk two percent you can do this framework for one limit order to be buying at thirty seven
fifty four and three quarters use the stop as explained here and do a second order the same
way but don't use this as your profit objective use this short term high here or the target i was
outlining thirty eight oh five and a half and then you would be able to get a run from here to here
on one that would close out and then the second one would hopefully run up in here and get the
daily range and you can do obviously better than you two and a quarter percent just on this one
you'd have two and a quarter twice because the one that you bought down here i'm sorry the one
you bought here that got out here that's your bank two and a quarter percent hypothetically
then the second one would be running here and rolling through that level up to here
so you could be making as much as four and a half percent more on the second position so what are
you really making six and three quarter percent one day two orders one trade
trade and a lot of you guys are trying to do those funded account challenges and they give you like
you got to make ten percent to do this if you learn how to trade and you learn what i'm teaching
you folks listen those numbers are achievable but you have to know what you're doing and also
how to weather drawdown drawdown would be having your account reduced from either its starting
balance or after you've made equity increases you start taking losses that's drawdown well that
drawdown has to be managed so if you have a trade and for instance say you took this hypothetical
trade here with one order and you got in at that 37 54 and three quarters and you got stopped out
down here okay you would have taken less than one percent loss so your next trade you should do half
of one percent why because number one you have emotions psychological impact of taking the loss
you're going to be most likely wanting to have revenge and you're probably going to want to do
more leverage than you should and you're probably going to want to get it faster than you should in
other words being patient is not going to be the right thing for you you're going to feel like
impatience is eating at you so therefore you have to hurry up get right back in there and try to get
your money back and that is a loser's cycle gambler's mentality so by reducing the risk
on your next trade once you take a loss then you have to make back 50 percent of what you lost so
in this case if you would have got stopped down here we'll just round it to 100 with commission
you have to make 50 back before you can go back to your full one percent risk
and that's it's easy that's easy to do it's not easy to follow this logic so what happens if you
take that second trade and risking a half of one percent and that trade gets knocked out to a loss
what size you use on your next trade one quarter of one percent and that's obviously the lowest
you can go with so you have to determine what your risk is and it's going to obviously reduce
the number of trades you can take that's why i tell everyone you there's a lot of you out here
that are starting on a shoestring meaning you don't have a lot of money and you're trying to
speculate with live funds with a $50 account or a hundred dollar account and i get it i understand
it's hard if you don't come from money if you don't have the resources where you are globally
it feels like you're out of reach learning the skill set okay i promise you if you learn the
skill set you can do funded account type things as a venture or find partners that'll come in
with you you don't need the money it doesn't have to be your money you can make a lot of money with
other people's money but funded accounts provide a way for you to go in with a very small amount of
money and you learn the skill set i'm laying down here in public you can walk right into any
money's funded account challenges okay if they want to call it a challenge and just walk right
through it and take it over and then secure whatever size account you're trying to go for
and then trade it soberly you know aim for 10% a month 15% a month
and just make that and stop don't try to push it don't try to get rich real quick you want that
10 to 15 percent a month coming into your hands after the split that you do with whatever that
account is you're registered with whatever funded account company it's helping you
find the scratch to get started
started
but knowing how to manage that drawdown will keep you from going into obviously blowing your account
it'll control the equity drawdown it won't be a sharp jagged falling off a cliff it'll be you run
up to new equity highs and you have a losing trade which is reasonable everyone has a losing
trade you may have a series of losing trades but if you take a one percent loss and then you take
another loss at half one percent and you take another loss at a quarter of one percent you're
only down one and three quarters percent that's not a lot of drawdown but you've now taken three
losing consecutive trades that's easy to come back from versus taking one percent loss then
saying okay i'm going to double up and try to make it back with two percent risk because i don't have
to just get half the position movement i took as a loss and then you take a full two percent loss
now you're down three percent on two trades then you go in again thinking well i'm going to do it
again with two percent or worse you go higher risking three percent or four percent and then
you use a stop or you move your stop opening up with more risk and then suddenly it's very easy
to fall into ten percent drawdown and then it becomes a psychological wrestling match
where now you feel embarrassed you're shamed you feel like you have to have it back otherwise
you're a failure when professional money managers they don't care about being in drawdown
they care about managing their expectations and the discipline that's required to operate and
engage they are not allowed to touch their account when they're highly charged or emotional
so that's all part of risk management it's not just the numbers game it's a psychological game
too but you have to manage that and quell that whole desire to get right back to where you were
before you took that loss that feeling comes because you are an infant in this industry
and that's not a knock against you okay it's the truth if you were working with me one-on-one and
i was standing in the same room with you i would say it to your face you're an infant if you think
like that it's infantile to think that way it's not a rude comment it's the facts because you
want to get your toy that was taken from you back right away and you don't need it back right away
when you have a loss or if you go through drawdown the professional money manager if you use it as
it's a loan that you're going to collect interest on when a bank lends out money is it crying about
how i had to give out your down payment for a home or your boat loan or some other purchase that
you made a loan with them with are you are you upset about giving you that big lump of money no
nope are they expecting to get it back right away no no in fact they don't want you to take it
and pay it off real quick because that's their business model they want to lend out the money
and get as much interest as possible so while we don't want to leave drawdown in long periods
out there we look at or at least i look at when i take a loss if i go into drawdown it's just a
loan i know i know i'm going to get interest on it because my career isn't going to be framed by
the last five trades or the last five weeks or the last five months or the last five years
i have a long-term view and that's the problem with being an infant in this industry
it's too easy for you to want to quit because you don't see past what's happened to you right now
or what happened to you last week or the last trade and that last trade that one singular event
you've made such a monumental experience out of and it's make it or break it every single trade
is a make it or break it i've read two people one on twitter and one on the comment section
of the videos i have and they're basically saying yeah i think i'm packing in i can't do this
and if that's true congratulations you you found where your breaking point is
and you're not willing to go any further into that and if you know yourself well
godspeed but there's a lot of folks that get frustrated and if you're going to quit you're
not going to post it on the internet you're not okay i believe these individuals that do that
they just want to be encouraged like don't don't stop me that's it's a cry for help
honestly if i would have had that as a medium when i was coming up i would have went on the
as a medium when i was coming up i would have went on the internet and said help i'm gonna quit
somebody stopped me from quitting i'm gonna walk out the door it's kind of like a a relationship
when your lady wants to leave she's not saying i'm leaving you and she really doesn't want to
leave she just wants to see what your reaction is going to be as you see her walking towards the
door or grabbing a couple things of her clothing if she's going to leave she ain't telling you
you're going to come home and her stuff is gone and if you're going to quit this industry you're
not going to talk about it you just ain't going to be here anymore so again roll your sleeves up
just understand this is what it's like to be a trader you're going to be in periods where it's
very difficult and no matter what you do what you follow what i taught you what somebody else taught
you whatever worked in the past you are going to encounter losing trades plural you're going to do
it wrong you're going to have an expectation in the marketplace it isn't going to pan out like
you thought guess what that means you may take a monetary loss and that's a tax on success
you have to pay it nobody gets around that nobody gets around it and some of you in here for whatever
reason think that you're going to stroll right on in here because you're going to be the exception
to the world and guess what folks i'm promising you you aren't that special if i wasn't that
special nobody's exempt from it you all we all every single speculator has to pay their toll
and occasionally guess what the ferryman's got his bony hand holding out waiting for you to drop
whatever the next sacrifice of your losing trade is going to be and you have control of how bad
that's going to be you limit it but you have to do the math and stick to it otherwise if you trade
willy-nilly well whatever happens i don't really use a hard stop but i know when i want to get out
i hate hearing traders say that that's so disappointing to hear because really what that
is communicating is you really don't have it together if you don't know where to place a stop
loss you really don't know what you're doing
you don't so with this model i've removed that guess that mystery your hard stop needs to be
placed period if it gets hit it's done you a favor period but if it does you that favor of protecting
and limiting risk it's your job as the trader to listen to the analyst next trade it provides
you'll have to manage the trade with less risk because you have a task now you have to come out
of drawdown no matter what the drawdown is you have to come back incrementally so let's assume
you do a two percent risk trade and you lose the full two percent your next trade you could only
risk one percent and it would be basically what i'm showing you here with one contract or one
limit order that contract it would be the equivalent of if you're doing two percent you
would be doing basically four micro lots entering at thirty seven fifty four and three quarters
hypothetical entry on the demo and your stop loss at thirty seven forty five and three quarters
nine points risk across four micro lots
twenty dollars per point
okay so if you take that full loss at two percent your next trade you can only do what's being
shown here one percent risk and you got to determine where is your trade defined in terms
of points or pips if it's 4x how much of a stop loss do you need in this case we're using this
factor here okay nine that's the number of points that's required for the stop for this
particular trade not every trade is going to require a static nine point stop sometimes
you can do a stop you know with five points it's hard i'm not suggesting you should be trying to
do that but other trades are going to require you to do what more than nine might be ten might be
twelve points so you have to consider what that's going to do for you in terms of risk
management and eventually you may get to the point where you lose so much in drawdown that
you really can't technically do one micro even if you have the margin to cover it
so that's why it's important for you to be very diligent about managing your risk
and controlling drawdown don't think oh well you know i'm going to start off with one percent
and then once you make a trade and it's easy think well i can do three percent because if i
can do three percent risk and i get a multiple of five r i think fifteen percent one trade and
what if i do that every day even better what if i do that in the morning session and in the afternoon
and if i can do that why not lose sleep and trade london too wow that's 45 in one day
good grief i could probably quit my job next sunday
i did that kind of stuff folks it doesn't work like that doesn't work like that at all so you
have to use low threshold objectives and work your way up from that your career is not going to be
10 trades and you made it
no longevity controlled risk impeccable risk management that's how you get here that's how
you arrive at consistently profitable and losing trades don't mean anything despite anybody watching
you if you do it publicly a losing trade is nothing but a tax on success that's it
all right stop management this is going to close the mentorship in terms of the teachings and past
this video i'll be doing obviously reviews and topical studies when i feel led to do so
but as far as the model itself and the mentorship okay for youtube this free series i did this is
done and you'll have everything that you need here every i'm confident in saying that what is
and you'll have everything that you need here every i'm confident in saying that what has been
provided to you after this discussion here you have enough and obviously the things i taught you
on the youtube channel and other lessons and maybe other future lessons i might do
they'll just be amplifications and help you refine what this has already given you freely
but stop management okay when you place your stop loss down here when can you and when do i
move my stop loss well you have to determine where you're getting in at
and where you're trying to get is the target so that's your range from 37 54 and three quarters
to 37 80 and a quarter so technically 25 and a half points okay so what is that 12 and three
quarters points something like that well let's round it to 12 and a half points if we see price
move 12 and a half points above the entry point that you enter that if it moves 12 and a half
points your stop loss can move 25 up from where what's 25 of what range where your stop loss is
in your entry so split that range in terms of points if this goes up 12 and a half points
which would be 50 of the expected range then your stop loss can be reduced or trimmed down to
25 percent so it's going to give you that little bit of a cookie that feel good moment you trimmed
some of the risk you're not jamming it up up above the break even because you're going to
worry about it you're just moving a little bit now when price moves to 75 percent of the expected
targeted range and it means from your entry to here if it moves 75 percent of that then the
stop goes to break even period there's your systematic movement of your stop loss you're
not jamming it to break even you're not going to be worried about getting stopped out you're going
to be more likely to be watching does it still keep reaching for your objective do down close
candles keep supporting price does it run below short-term loan and run higher with a lot of
energy because it took short-term sell stops out is it dropping down to a fair value gap
and reaccumulating and sending another higher price leg higher that's what you're watching
that's the things that you're looking for and as long as it's doing those things collectively or
individually you are one side that means you're on the right side of the market and keep holding
for your position to hit target if you are doing multiple positions say you're doing competition
level leverage and for me that's anywhere between the range of three percent to four and a half
percent then you're going to be looking to take partials okay and that partial might be you know
once it goes 20 points in your favor you have a static number it always hits 15 or 20 once it does
that you no matter what you're doing you take something off okay that's something you might
want to incorporate in your own trading model as well but that part is for you to determine don't
let me give you static rules that are considered you cast in stone ironclad can't change it you
know i hate doing it with my students because it takes away the uniqueness the individualism
that you're bringing as the trader to your own model so these are just basic foundational
points that i think will serve you well but you're going to obviously evolve and come up with better
ways that meet your expectations and also fit your personality okay so i think that's going to be it
and i absolutely want to congratulate all of you that if you've gone through every single one of
these videos if you've done the work and back testing and looking at things and studying
and you're convinced that the pattern is really there kudos to you okay for those that have not
got it yet my encouragement is for you to keep doing it and i promise it won't take you long
in fact if you just started and you just found this channel i promise you if you give it six
months you'll see things that you've never saw before but at the end of one full year because
it might take some of you to do that you'll have it you'll understand what you're looking for
doesn't mean you're going to be trading every single day it doesn't mean you're going to know
the bias every single day doesn't mean you're not going to have losing trades it means that
you're going to know what you're doing and even though you may have short-term hardships with
being stopped out or missing moves or reading it wrong you still will have enough faith in this
model because you know it will repeat in the future more times than it fails and i'm challenging you
to determine whether that statement is true or not until next time good luck and good trading